nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction les États-Unis à l'occasion
des élections de mi-mandat du 8 novembre
pour comprendre les enjeux de ce scrutin
notre correspondante Fanny Allard a
traversé une partie du pays 2000 km du
nord au sud le long du fleuve
Mississippi jusqu'à la Nouvelle-Orléans
avec les Américains qu'il y a rencontré
elle a parlé du racisme du droit à
l'avortement des armes à feu de
l'inflation ou du changement climatique
autant de sujets qui ont fait
l'actualité des deux premières années de
mandat du président Biden et qui vont
être déterminants à l'occasion de ces
mythes c'est un reportage signé
[Musique]
nous rejoignons le fleuve Mississippi
dans le Minnesota aminéa police ville
devenue le symbole international des
violences policières aux États-Unis
après la mort de Georges Floyd en mai
2020 depuis au moins quatre hommes noirs
ont été tués par la police de la ville
alors qu'il n'était pas armé parmi eux
donterright un jeune homme de 20 ans
arrêté lors d'un contrôle routier en
avril 2021
vous voyez il avait la peau claire et il
a quand même été contrôlé par la police
je n'aurais jamais imaginé un instant
que ça puisse arriver à notre famille
nous ne sommes pas des gangsters nous ne
faisons de mal à personne nous sommes
des gens bien ça n'aurait pas dû nous
arriver
tenté de fuir la policière qui
l'interpellait elle l'a alors abattu et
a ensuite affirmé avoir confondu son
Taser avec son arme à feu malgré 26 ans
de service pour ce père aujourd'hui
endeuillé c'est intolérable il y a
vraiment un problème avec la formation
de la police et la manière dont
fonctionne le système je suis persuadé
que si mon fils avait eu les yeux bleus
et les cheveux blonds il serait encore
en vie aujourd'hui
un tiers des policiers a quitté son
emploi depuis 2020 l'institution tente
de se réformer elle a notamment mis en
place des équipes non armées
d'application de la loi réduit les
heures de travail des policiers et veut
regagner la confiance de la population
j'essaye d'interagir avec la communauté
car beaucoup de gens ne nous connaissent
pas ils ne voient que l'uniforme et
l'associe à ceux qui s'est passé en mai
2020 mais nous ne sommes pas tous comme
ça derrière l'uniforme il y a des
individus une réalité pourtant difficile
à défendre
économique et la fin de la violence
policière si un candidat peut garantir
cela alors nous voterons pour lui mais
si ce n'est pas le cas nous irons voir
ailleurs
aux États-Unis la police tue 6 fois plus
qu'en France un constat devant lequel
les démocrates sont Blin puissantes et
qui pourrait bien leur faire perdre le
vote des afro-américains
direction à présent le Wisconsin ou
l'avortement est devenu illégal
[Musique]
sa moi est à 23 ans tombé enceinte par
accident au mois de mai elle devait
avorter à 230 km d'ici le jour où la
Cour suprême des États-Unis a révoqué la
rero viewade
une amie devait me conduire elle est
arrivée chez moi tout était prêt et j'ai
reçu une notification sur mon téléphone
qui disait que review Wade était annulée
je recevais un coup de fil du planning
familial pour me prévenir qu'il ne
pourrait pas me recevoir car
l'avortement était devenu illégal
je t'ai furieuse pour l'impact de cette
décision sur notre pays et pour son
impact sur moi
étudiante le jour serveuse la nuit la
jeune femme n'aurait pas eu les moyens
d'élever un enfant seul elle a
finalement pu se rendre dans les
tavoisins du Minnesota pour interrompre
sa grossesse
ça a été extrêmement dur pour moi mais
je me sens quand même privilégié parce
que je suis à l'université j'ai un
boulot à une voiture
c'était une situation terrible mais je
n'imagine pas ce que ça doit être quand
on a pas les moyens
et je dois dire qu'aujourd'hui parmi
tous les problèmes auxquels fait face
notre pays le droit des femmes et ce qui
compte le plus pour moi
le Wisconsin est revenu à l'application
d'une loi de 1849 qui interdit
l'avortement même en cas de viol ou
d'inceste sauf s'il y a danger pour la
vie de la mer pour les défenseurs des
droits reproductifs le seul espoir d'un
retour en arrière et donc de voter le 8
novembre bonjour vous êtes Laura oui
bonjour Laura je m'appelle Joella je
fais partie des militants du planning
familial du Wisconsin nous voulons
savoir comment les membres de la
communauté appréhendent l'annulation de
rovy Wade il faut savoir qu'il existe
des moyens de rétablir l'avortement
légal
et moi je suis inquiète mais savoir que
des gens sont prêts à se battre pour ce
que nous méritons toutes ça me donne de
l'espoir
face à la situation le planning familial
a lancé une campagne nationale de 50
millions de dollars pour pousser la
population aux urnes
que cette loi soit codifiée c'est
pourquoi il est essentiel que nous
élisions des représentants qui se
battront pour rétablir l'accès à
l'avortement à l'échelle législative et
judiciaire
partout aux États-Unis les femmes se
mobilisent et s'inscrivent en masse sur
les listes électorales dans le Wisconsin
les nouvelles électrices seraient 17%
plus nombreuses que les hommes
nous poursuivons la route 800 km au sud
pour rejoindre la deuxième ville la plus
grande du Missouri sainte-louis
longtemps baptisé capital américaine du
meurtre elle est l'une des villes les
plus touchées par la violence par armes
à feu ce père de quatre enfants en a
payé le prix sa fille aînée a été tuée
au mois d'août
alors qu'elle conduisait simplement sur
la voie publique elle a été touchée par
une balle perdue
nous supposons qu'elle s'est retrouvée
au milieu d'un règlement de compte mais
elle ne faisait rien de mal elle n'avait
rien à voir là-dedans elle était juste
en train de conduire
avait 25 ans et une petite fille de 5
ans elle fait partie des plus de 157
personnes tuées depuis janvier à
sainte-louis pour son père il y a
urgence à réformer la législation sur
les armes
je pense que nous sommes collectivement
irresponsables et la prolifération des
armes dans ce pays si on ne fait rien si
nous ne menons pas des réformes
profondes nous n'exerçons pas de
pression sur nos députés et sur nos
hommes politiques en général
si on ne fait rien on verra en
permanence des gens blessés tués
assassinés sans aucune raison
le plus élevé de mort par balle aux
États-Unis dans cet état conservateur du
Midwest les lois sur le port d'armes
sont parmi les plus souples du pays il
est par exemple légal de porter un
pistolet chargé en public sans avoir de
permis
donc vous allez remplir la section B ça
commence ici avec votre nom et ça
termine avec votre signature lieu de
naissance ville état ta taille poids
sexe date de naissance
j'ai ce revendeur agréé c'est la loi
fédérale qui est en vigueur elle exige
une vérification des antécédents pour
l'achat d'une arme mais la loi du
Missouri elle n'exige rien du tout
la plupart des incidents liés aux armes
à feu ne sont pas perpétrés par des gens
qui respectent la loi
les lois sont adaptées aux gens qui les
respectent
elles sont ignorées par beaucoup
d'autres
cette année le crime a augmenté dans
toutes les grandes villes du pays les
électeurs sont d'accord sur la nécessité
d'y mettre fin mais pas sur les
solutions les démocrates souhaitent des
lois plus strictes alors que les
républicains eux prêchent pour davantage
de maintien de l'ordre
[Musique]
nous quittons le Midwest pour rallier
Memphis dans le Tennessee
durement touché par la pandémie la ville
du King et du blues souffrent désormais
de l'inflation
Sandy ochmani dirige ici une compagnie
de transport privé
votre réservation d'aujourd'hui à 15h
pour la première fois en 20 ans elle a
dû augmenter ses prix de 15 dollars par
heure en raison de la hausse du prix de
l'essence
ce n'est pas que l'essence le problème
mon assurance a aussi augmenté le prix
des voitures a augmenté même les
boissons qu'on met dans les voitures
pour les clients ont augmenté les
serviettes tout
une situation tellement précaire pour
cette chef d'entreprise quel envisage de
vendre sa société en attendant pour
minimiser ses coûts Sandy fait la chasse
aux pompes les moins chères on va
essayer cette station de Shell ici je
devrais avoir au moins 5 centimes de
réduction j'utilisais carte de crédit
différente pour avoir des réductions en
litres c'est combien ici 3 dollars 79
c'est pas mal
dans le sud américain l'inflation a
atteint presque 9% au mois de septembre
contre un peu plus de 8% à l'échelle
nationale pour Sandy pas de doute c'est
la faute des démocrates
chaque fois qu'on a eu un président
républicain le pays allait bien
diriger le pays comme un homme
d'affaires
et ça marchait bien pour nous
l'inflation touche tous les secteurs et
notamment celui de l'agriculture à
quelques kilomètres de Memphis dans la
région du delta Marvin redit cultive le
soja mais cette année il travaille à
perte
je cultive environ 300 acres de terre
soit 120 hectares
et mon cou d'exploitation est passé de
200 dollars par acre à 300 puis 320
dollars par acre
moi tout ce que je veux c'est fournir un
produit de qualité
mais en faisant un profit qui me permet
de payer mes factures
l'inflation s'est aggravée après la
guerre en Ukraine conséquence les prix
du diesel et des engrais ont doublé
alors pour les dépenses Marvin compte
sur la solidarité entre fermiers
on essaie de mettre en commun notre
équipement d'utiliser ce que j'ai et
qu'il n'a pas et vice versa plutôt que
d'acheter tous les deux la même chose ça
fait des économies
l'inflation est au cœur des
préoccupations des Américains à quelques
jours des élections de mi-mandat les
sondages montrent que les électeurs sont
plus enclins à faire confiance aux
républicains pour résoudre les problèmes
économiques
après plus de 2500 km dernière étape la
Nouvelle-Orléans en Louisiane
sortie de terre il y a plus de 300 ans
la ville est plus que jamais menacée par
le changement climatique alors pour se
protéger des ouragans elle a investi 14
milliards de dollars dans ces 10
n'est pas un système parfait mais ça
diminue les risques le changement
climatique rend tout le sud de la
Louisiane vulnérable au total 560 km de
mur eau de 6 à 8 mètres encadre la ville
le dispositif a résisté en 2021 lors de
la tempête sida mais reste fragile
ont constamment besoin de maintenance
ici regardez on peut justement voir
qu'une partie de la digue est en train
de couler ces deux parties ont été
nivelées et maintenant vous voyez il y a
5 cm de différence entre les deux
Spice en plus des catastrophes
naturelles la Louisiane est soumise à la
rapid montée des eaux d'ici 2050 le
niveau de la mère devrait monter de 60
cm
si vous regardez dans cette direction
vous allez apercevoir une poignée
d'arbres morts
c'était une forêt de cyprès qui faisait
tampon et protégeait la Nouvelle-Orléans
des tempêtes des ouragans et de l'eau
face à cette situation de nombreuses
initiatives locales voient le jour cette
entreprise recycle le verre de la
Nouvelle-Orléans pour le transformer en
sable dans l'espoir de reconstruire la
côte
nous recevons environ 15 tonnes de verre
par semaine tout ce qui est broyé tombe
dans cet entonnoir
et les morceaux les plus lourds tombent
directement dans ce sac et ça c'est
notre produit de sortie
le sable récolté est ensuite mis dans
des sacs en toile de jute qui se
désagrègent au bout de 6 mois et
permettent aux nouveaux matériaux de
s'intégrer à l'environnement
en tout 1250 tonnes de verre ont déjà
été recyclés par Alex et ses collègues
la côte louisianaise perd l'équivalent
d'un terrain de foot de terre toutes les
100 minutes on ne peut pas remplacer ça
mais on peut ralentir lesrosions en
déployant notre sable à des endroits
stratégiques
les riverains viennent ici trois fois
par semaine pour déposer leur bouteilles
quel impact a vraiment tout ce vert
ça dépend mais si c'est bien réparti 5
tonnes peuvent changer la trajectoire
d'un marais
il y a toujours eu des oppositions à la
restauration de la côte en Louisiane
toute ma vie ça a été le sujet de débat
alors la voir aujourd'hui disparaître
c'est un choc
ces gars-là mènent le combat moi je le
fais en recyclant et en allant voter
aller voter le 8 novembre prochain les
louisianais sont attendus au bureau de
vote comme tous les citoyens américains
mais seule la moitié des électeurs
considère le climat comme l'une de ses
priorités loin derrière l'économie la
sécurité et l'avortement
et voilà pour cette Amérique qui va
voter dans quelques jours des élections
et une campagne que vous pouvez suivre
sur France 24 dans toutes nos éditions
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur France 24
[Musique]